[Music]
hey I'm rheumatic this show I watched
the first episode it is such a departure
for you what did you learn about
yourself making this and really tackling
this type of subject matter I just I
don't know I learned a lot I think I I
think we all in this cast about to push
ourselves and be vulnerable and and it's
been hard and there's been fun days and
there's a really tough days but I'm so
lucky to be working with the people that
I'm working with I'm so thankful for the
warm
I think safe space that we've created on
set to be able to go to those places and
and yeah I'm just you know part of it
how does it feel knowing that Drake
wanted you for this role I don't know I
don't know if he was involved in the
casting but I will say that it's you
know it's definitely we're lucky to have
someone to uh who believes in the show
as well I feel like with this character
I mean you're tackling anxiety you're
tackling drug addiction but when I think
about the career that you've had you
have a seamless perfect reputation
you're such a good role model what's
been the secret to keeping that good
head on your shoulders I mean there's no
secret really I just try to take my time
and know I think I have a great group of
people around me a great base and that's
really important but I think just taking
your time trying to push myself without
being hard on myself is kind of always
finding the balance
how do you step it up without knocking
yourself down you know so it's just some
20 nut balance and figuring it out one
step at a time and knowing that like
it's just a process you know it's day by
day you can't force anything just let it
let it live let it go sometimes that's
your way of kind of breaking out of that
child star molding away I'm not really I
think I just have been slowly kind of
growing out of that phase of my life in
career and I just you know I just take
steps so much
that's zendaya opening up to et about
her new HBO series euphoria but when it
comes to rumors she'll be starring in
Disney's live-action remake of the
Little Mermaid
she played coy I'm sure it'll be great
when they make it and I'll go see it
like everyone else oh my gosh seaweed me
now
[Music]